cyber monday turns into psycho Monday
from the TV ads selling cheap consumer
goods to the politicians trying to sell
themselves we examine all of the
sociopathy them speaking of psychos the
deep state goes on offense before the
Inspector General releases his report on
the origins of the Russia investigation
can we the people beat the bureaucrats
all that and more I'm Michael Knowles
and this is the Michael Noel's show
[Music]
there is actually a connection I promise
you between a ridiculous viral ad for
peloton bicycles and the 2020 Democratic
candidates for president there is a few
people have picked up on it we will get
to that in a second first I've got to
thank our friends over at paint your
life guys listen to me
pay attention stop your car whatever
you're doing pay attention I know that
you're shopping for Christmas presents
right now if you want to give a truly
meaningful gift you have got to try
paint your life calm I freaking love
this product
what is paint your life paint your life
is when you get an original painting of
yourself or your family or your kids or
a special place or a pet that you love
or whatever at a price that you can
afford from paint your life calm it is a
true painting it is done by hand by a
world-class artist created from a
favorite photo so it's very easy you
don't need to go there and sit and pose
for three days you upload a photo it
makes the perfect Christmas gift you
choose the artist whose work you most
admire and you work with them throughout
the process until every detail is
perfect there's no risk here if you
don't love the final painting your money
is refunded I was extremely skeptical of
this product I thought there is no way
that you can actually have a high
quality hand done painting made from a
photograph online I just didn't think I
was gonna work so of course I didn't use
it on a painting that I wanted to have
made for myself I did it for my
step-brother for his wedding I upload
this painting of him and his wife in
Grand Central this is a ton of detail
there I'm getting proofs threat the
whole process I get to approve I get to
pick the frame I get to do everything
about it it comes it's big it's
beautiful
the art is exquisite I'm very particular
when it comes to art I love this thing
I'm obviously going back you should go
back to right now you should for a
limited time I get 30% off of your
painting that is a limited time 30% off
free shipping get this special offer by
texting Michael mi CH AE L to 64,000
very simple
text Michael to 64,000 mi CH AE L to
64,000 all right so most of the stories
from this crazy Cyber Monday yesterday
were strictly political not all of them
I want to start with one that was not
strictly political it was a cyber monday
ad for peloton stationary bicycles
obviously all the companies are trying
to sell their product on Black Friday
and Cyber Monday peloton bicycles if you
haven't seen them it's actually a very
cool product I kind of want to have one
of these products except this ad is
making me less likely to buy their
product
it's a stationary bicycle and you can
kind of Skype in or you know
videoconference in to these classes and
you can do it from your own home and it
seems kind of like a cool product this
ad had every single thing wrong with it
take a listen first ride I mean the
wristband excited let's do this five
days in a row you surprised
exam day rising with the Sun I was
totally worth it Boston a year ago I
didn't realize how much this would
change me thank you
this holiday give the gift of Palatine
oh what what on let's just begin from
the very beginning on everything wrong
with this ad first what kind of
psychopath gets his wife a stationary
bicycle for Christmas that is to say you
know your what is your wife one she
wants jewelry she wants clothing she
wants I don't know something and you say
hey honey you're looking a little puffy
these days they're right a little round
around the edges so I'm gonna maybe get
you a little bicycle you're gonna
workout for the next 12 months and and
then by the way you're gonna have to
record it you're gonna have to Instagram
it you're gonna have to stream it so
that in one year next Christmas we're
gonna review the results and see how you
did losing all that extra weight so
that's the first part that's a little
odd then she says she's really nervous
why is she nervous to get on a
stationary bicycle that is the safest
most basic activity you could possibly
engage in it's not even an outdoor
bicycle it's a bicycle you do in your
own living room maybe she's nervous
because she's got this psycho husband
who's making her work out for an entire
year and that's her Christmas present
then she's instagramming herself while
sitting on the stationary bike I guess
perhaps is proof that she actually did
it for her her husband except there is
no proof of it because from the
beginning to the end she looks exactly
the same which makes sense because they
obviously shot this over the course of
one or two days tops
and so she didn't have time to lose a
lot of weight not that she had to lose
weight in the first place she just ends
up sort of sweaty at the end so I guess
that's what changed in her life but then
how does she get to the end and say I
didn't realize my life would change so
much you know from from the beginning to
the end how did your life change well
here's one way your life changed weird
the kid go at the beginning of the ad
there was a kid then by the end of the
ad there's no kid that's a little weird
do they really need to spend two
Christmases two Christmases talking
about this bicycle doesn't make a lot
every single second of the ad makes you
more curious as to how this ad got May
and if you're me it makes me less likely
every second of the way to to get this
bicycle this ad was ratioed on YouTube
15 to 1 15 dislikes for everyone like
and yet the ad went viral it went viral
because it's such an absurd terrible add
some people are saying that the joke's
on all of us because the stock for
peloton bicycles rose 5% yesterday now
that's true that's only part of the
story their stock is actually way up
this whole month it's up like 45 percent
or something so I'm not sure that you
could really credit this ad for for the
increase in the price this is still an
objectively bad ad and this is where the
political aspect of this ad comes in or
at least the political significance
because there's this big debate is it a
good ad because we're all talking about
peloton or is it a bad ad because it
makes peloton look kind of stupid and
weird this is an objectively bad ad it's
a bad ad because it doesn't make any
sense it puts the product in a bad light
and even though some people are talking
about it in the long run I don't think
this helps them yes some people are
talking about peloton a lot of people
are talking about peloton now you could
have also gotten people to talk about
peloton by making the ad a commercial of
a big fat naked guy walking on-screen
and vomiting right if that was the ad
the wind even a bicycle owner it was
just a big fat naked guy who walks on
the screen and vomits on screen we would
all be talking about peloton - it would
have gotten belladonna ville a lot of
attention maybe their stock would have
gone up I don't know but it wouldn't be
great in the long run it would be the
wrong kind of attention in the long run
that is what is happening in the
Democratic primaries the Democratic
primaries are this peloton ad every
single one of these candidates just
about is doing this peloton ad lots of
flash lots of attention seeking works
for the short term gives them a boost in
the short term not great
in the long run one of the great
examples of that is beta O'Rourke beta
or orc is a walking talking peloton
bicycle ad because he comes out there
writing and this whole candidacy doesn't
make a whole lot of sense he's just
an ex-congressman and a failed Senate
candidate but for some reason we're all
talking about it and he's bicycling and
he's he's making jokes with his wife and
he's filming his dentist visit it's
getting them a lot of attention it gets
him to rise in the polls I get some a
Vanity Fair cover and then people
realize oh wait a second now this isn't
great this isn't gonna last threat the
long run another example of this Kamala
Harris Kamala Harris bursts onto the
scene in the early days of the primary
and it's all flash it's all attention
seeking its negative attention but its
attention she plays the race card
she calls Joe Biden a racist she talks
about smoking blunts while listening to
Snoop Dogg before Snoop Dogg ever
released an album right she's getting
all this attention she is convinced that
she's a top-tier candidate here's Kamala
Harris back in July this is gonna sound
immodest but I'm obviously a top-tier
candidate and so I did expect that I
would be on the stage and take hits
tonight because there are a lot of
people that are trying to make the stage
for the next debate okay she said she's
a top-tier candidate and it sure looked
like that back in those early days when
she's getting all of this negative
attention where is she now she's
trailing Mike Bloomberg she's trailing
Mike Bloomberg guy who's barely in the
race there was a poll that just came out
it's a poll from Harvard Harris Mike
Bloomberg is entering the race at about
6% so he's not doing well he's got like
bado numbers right
he's got 6% commonly Harris is down at
2% she went from a top-tier candidate at
least in her own mind to 2% trailing the
ex mayor of New York who's half a
Democrat who's a billionaire who's a
white guy who's should not be doing well
in this Democratic primary and who isn't
doing well but he's doing better than
her he's up three points she's down two
points because all the attention that
Kamala Harris got was sizzle it was all
sizzle no steak
same thing for Elizabeth Warren it's not
even just these low tier candidates like
beta or Kamala or the people that we
forget Liz Warren - Liz Warren who's now
considered a top tier candidate all
sizzle no stake in the case of Elizabeth
Warren it's all smoke signals no peyote
Elizabeth Warren
comes out right a couple weeks ago she
unveils her health care plan and this
gets her a lot of attention
52 trillion dollar plan she has no idea
she's gonna pay for it she says that
she's gonna pay for it by taxing
billionaires that doesn't make any sense
621 billionaires in the country their
combined net worth is about three point
two trillion dollars if she took away
all of their money it wouldn't get her
through one year of her plan but it gets
a lot of attention she's rising up all
the Momentum's with Elizabeth Warren and
then once people stop and consider that
plan she starts to tank in the polls now
once you get into this cycle once you
get into the cycle of requiring all of
this just negative attention and
attention at all costs to stay relevant
to stay in the headlines it it creates a
very vicious cycle so now she's out of
the news for a little bit all that good
press that came quickly has fizzled so
she's trying to recapture it by even
more radical plans she just endorsed the
other day getting rid of the electoral
college here she is
what are your thoughts on the electoral
college I want to get rid of it so
here's my goal my goal is to get elected
and then to be the last American
president elected by the electoral
college
I want the second term to be that I got
elected by direct vote I'm ready
popular vote I just think this is how a
democracy should work call me
old-fashioned but I think the person who
gets the most votes should win all right
that doesn't make a lot of sense for a
number of reasons first of all called me
old-fashioned but I think that we should
overturn over 200 years of American
precedent in electing our president that
doesn't make any sense if you were
old-fashioned you would support this
institution the Electoral College which
has served our country very very well
since its founding but she won't do that
it's amazing they talk about how Donald
Trump is overturning norms and
traditions in our country it's koto is
totally unprecedented he's a radical
he's overturning norms these people are
trying to overturn all of the basic
norms of our country they're trying to
overturn the first amendment the second
amendment the electoral college it's
right overturn all of these things and
yet they attack Trump for it this this
point she's making though doesn't make a
lot of sense for another reason
she says the electoral college is
totally corrupt it's terrible it's an
awful thing it's undemocratic so she's
saying I want to when I get elected I
promise to abolish that corrupt terrible
undemocratic untrustworthy institution
that elected me president that doesn't
have a whole lot of ring to it doesn't
make sense and the argument at least
from the left were the only people
making this argument the argument to get
rid of the electoral college is that
there's no way Democrats can win with
the electoral college because we've now
twice had a situation in the last 30
years where our last 20 years I guess
where a president got elected even
though he lost the popular vote now we
don't elect presidents on the popular
vote we are the United States of America
not the United people of America we have
a federal system here and the vote for
president is more complicated than just
some guy going to the polls so that New
York and LA and San Francisco dominate
every presidential election but if the
argument is that Democrats can't win
with the electoral college and
a Democrat wins with the electoral
college then the argument for getting
rid of the electoral college sort of
goes away it's radical she just needs to
say it to get more more press because
she's lost a little bit of her momentum
again polls keep showing that people
don't want this kind of radicalism the
problem for these candidates is they
require the radicalism to stay in the
news
she's stepped in it again getting even
more negative attention throwing off
much of the race and another candidate
is waiting in the wings we will get to
that in a second but first I've got to
thank our friends over at ring I love
feeling safe and the knowledge that my
home is secure this season can be a
whirlwind of deliveries and visitors a
holiday travel right so it is the best
time of year to upgrade your doorbell
and keep an eye on your home no matter
where the holidays take you ring helps
you stay connected to your home from
anywhere from anywhere so if there's a
package delivery you ordered some
Christmas present or there's a surprise
visitor maybe your mother-in-law you
will get an alert you will be able to
see hear and speak to that person all
from your phone whether in your in your
bedroom or your at the office or you're
on a beach somewhere so if you're at
home right the package delivery guy
comes even speak to him and say leave it
there put it there whatever fits your
mother-in-law you can stay perfectly
perfectly still and hope that without
movement she doesn't see you thinks
nobody is home and goes away you can
check in anytime on your home for some
much-needed holiday peace of mind I love
it especially I'm on the road a fair bit
you know I'm traveling around speaking
at different colleges sweet a little
lease is a pretty good shot she knows
how to handle a firearm but I feel very
safe knowing that we can take a look at
our home from anywhere as a listener you
have a special holiday offer on a ring
starter kit available right now with a
ring video doorbell too and
motion-activated floodlight camera the
starter kit has everything you need to
start building a ring of security around
your home no matter what this holiday
season brings with ring you were always
home just go right now because this
makes a great gift by the way
I've given these out as housewarming
presents and
love them and they look so cool and they
make you feel like you're living in the
Jetsons and the best part for you the
gift-giver
they're not very expensive so you get to
seem like a really really cool guy you
know but you don't have to spend a ton
of money go to ring.com slash Knowles
Kaena wles that is ring.com slash
Knowles cater wles additional terms may
apply
so Elizabeth Warren steps in it again
she's getting even more much more
negative attention beyond policy on the
personal front liz warren is one of the
most shameless liars in the country
right she's lied for decades about being
Indian she lied about being the first
nursing mother to take the bar exam in
New Jersey she said that there's no
reason to believe that that is true she
lied about being a single mother when
she met her second husband she wasn't
she was married when she met her second
husband and she left her first husband
for her second husband she lied about
getting fired from teaching because she
was pregnant how do we know she lied
about it because she told us the true
story years ago and now she's changed
the true story which is that she wasn't
fit for teaching she didn't want to do
what she wanted to stay home were the
kids
now it's that she was the victim of some
awful oppression and that was all
because she was pregnant now she's lying
again another major lie from Elizabeth
Warren she's lying about her kid going
to public school so you heard that she
said you you kid probably went to
private school no no my kids went to
public school they didn't that's not
true Warren's daughter Amelia went to
public schools for the entirety of her
elementary and high school education but
her son Alex spent most of his school
years at one of the most prestigious
private schools in the country and an
elite private school called the
Haverford School this was according to
yearbooks from the Haverford school that
were obtained by the Washington free
beacon so technically not a total lie
right because if her son Alex went to
public school for even one year she can
say my kids went to public schools yeah
they went for a little bit I don't know
they went by there's like
a friend of mine used to say hey Michael
you know I went to Harvard yeah but they
were closed the day I showed up it's
it's like saying you know you take a
tour of Alcatraz when you're in San
Francisco and you say yeah I've been to
prison uh I've been to prison I just got
out well I get yeah you've been there
but you didn't you haven't actually been
to prison this you could go to public
school for a year or two but if you
spend the majority of your formative
years you get most of your education in
a private school especially a very fancy
private school then you didn't send your
kids to public schools but she's a
pathological liar
total psycho who lies about this kind of
stuff who lies about being a Native
American who lies about that well funny
you should ask Michael speaking of these
pathological liars speaking of these
psycho blonde female Democratic
candidates guess who is waiting in the
wings looking at this mayhem and
destruction in the Democratic 2020
primary and just clamoring to get back
into it I'll give you one guess when she
came to the end of her career she did
this final kind of endorsement
advertising campaign and the tagline was
forget me why did that appeal to Hillary
well what she was saying as she retired
was you know I want to make way for new
people you know forget me forget my
accomplishments let's clear the decks
let's encourage more young people not
only to play football but run for office
be a great chef be a writer be whatever
and I loved that hmm hold on you loved
that Hillary that does not sound like
the Hillary Clinton I know because the
Hillary Clinton I know first lady of
Arkansas then she's the first lady of
the United States and she's the first
lady on this idea of
buy-one-get-one-free that's how Bill
Clinton ran for president in 1992 he
said you get me but you also get Hillary
Clinton I can't even imagine what his
campaign advisers told him like a ixnay
on the Hillary Hey all right the people
don't really like her that much so he
gets he becomes president he gives
Hillary the opportunity to try to put
health care through it totally flops
because she's really not that talented a
politician other
being married to Bill Clinton and then
she just walks away right she moves on
and let someone else have the spotlight
no she forces herself into a Senate seat
from New York pushes other people out of
the way moves to New York randomly total
carpetbagger
and through the sheer power of Clinton's
presidency becomes senator then she runs
for president gets rejected by the
American people again she is appointed
Secretary of State by Barack Obama
because keep your friends close and your
enemies closer she runs for president
2016 gets rejected by the American
people again but then she steps away
right doesn't she want to step away
she's gonna make room for four other
people to take their opportunities right
right uh not so fast and where are you
are you saying forget me is that your
mantra now not yet
because the rumor mill is flying that I
could you could step back into the ring
yeah I hear that
I especially have been deluged and you
know the last few weeks with thinking
about doing that but right now I'm not
at all you know planning that I'd have
to make up my mind really quickly
because it's moving very fast but I do
want to continue to influence the debate
not yet no well hold on a second there I
like other people moving out of the way
for other people especially me I myself
do not like getting out of the way for
talent to come up so Hilary obviously
still wants to run she desperately wants
to run she has left the door open she's
sent her senior advisors like Phillip
Bryan's to go on television and stoke
the speculation about whether or not she
will run why is she even doing this
right now she's doing this right now
because the field is weak because
frankly this woman this woman shameless
psycho one of the least popular women in
America she is pretty much the best that
they've got who else is it gonna be it's
gonna be Joe Biden with his eyes
exploding his teeth falling out and
biting his wife's finger I don't I don't
know he's collapsing and I always
collapsing in New Hampshire
sometimes collapsing maybe on the
campaign trail this is gonna be pastor
Pete Buddha jej no I don't think so he's
he's really off-putting is it gonna be
Elizabeth Warren her numbers of 10th in
recent days gonna be commonly Harris
she's at 2% is it gonna be Mike
Bloomberg is the new entrant he's at 6%
we need to get rid of this New York
billionaire and replaced him with a New
York billionaire I don't think so
they've got nobody they've gotten so
much attention these Democratic
candidates over the past three years by
talking about how terrible Trump is in
the Russia investigation and the taxes
and stormy Daniels and Ukraine and and
yet when you finally put the spotlight
on them you say okay in the long run are
you really going to be what America is
asking for they all collapse they're all
collapsing to the point that the
Democratic Party is seriously
considering we're
turning to Hillary Clinton not great and
so now that the left is looking at their
own candidates saying this is not
looking good they're turning their
attention away from them back onto
president Trump and they're gonna try to
win the 2020 election it's not by
putting forward really good candidates
who are really popular but by sabotaging
president Trump's campaign this is
happening now at the highest levels of
Google and YouTube we have evidence of
it we'll get to that in a second first I
got to thank our friend server Equipe
there are very few habits that you can
get into regularly that will help your
health quite like just brushing your
teeth doing a good job
brushing your teeth that's why most
people brush their teeth very well I'd
do it strictly at a vanity I just want
my teeth to look nice and shiny
that's where equipped the makers of quip
electronic toothbrush comes in quips
electric toothbrush has sensitive sonic
vibrations with a built-in timer and
30-second pulses to guide a full and
even clean quip makes it easy to stick
to a healthy brushing habit starting
with an electric toothbrush refillable
floss and anti cavity toothpaste the
quip floss dispenser comes with pre
marked string to help you use just
enough is if you're like me you never
know how much floss you're supposed to
use so you pull it out you pretty much
could decorate your Christmas tree with
it Plus quip delivers fresh brush heads
floss toothpaste refills to your door
every three months with free shipping so
your routine is always right I brush
with a regular toothbrush now to me that
feels like brushing with a stick you
need to get an electric toothbrush it's
so much better it keeps your teeth so
much whiter and healthier join over 3
million healthy mouths and get quipped
today starting at just 25 dollars if you
go to get quip dot-com slash Michael mi
CH AE L right now you will get your
first refill for free that is your first
refill free at get quip Carmichael mi CH
AE L GE t qu IP comm slash michael quip
the good habits company got a lot more
to get to we got to get to how Google is
trying to sabotage the Trump campaign we
have got to get to actually there's
there's a silver lining in that story
because the mainstream media actually
did their job
we've got to get to Lisa page the FBI
bureaucrat who was caught in text
messages talking about how they were
gonna try to overturn the 2016 election
we will get to the reaction from the
deep to the deep state rather from the
Trump DOJ lots of shenanigans going on
that very few people are reporting on we
will get to all of that first I've got
to say goodbye to Facebook and YouTube
head on over to Daley wire.com what do
you get you get me you get the Indra
Clavin show you get the Ben Shapiro show
you get the mount wall show you can't
ask questions in the mailbag you get
another Kingdom another Kingdom we're in
our third and final season super popular
show which I'm very pleased about but
it's a really really good show I can say
that because all I do is read the words
that drew Clavin wrote it is a really
profound novel it's a really profound
piece of work I'm so pleased and
privileged to be a part of it really
recommend especially if you're looking
for something to get into this Christmas
season it's really really good to listen
to and you get most importantly the
leftist here's tumblr I don't know if
you saw it but yesterday the left-wing
outlet now this they make all these
really annoying videos on social media
now this did a big hit piece on us and
me drew Matt Daly wire talking about how
terrible it is that we're really
successful on social media and they've
put this hit piece out of Gaiden Judd
legume I think is his name he was so
upset in this video about how the Daily
wire is really successful
thanks to listeners like you and so
obviously I wanted to thank now this for
the free promotion but I wanted to thank
them also for their tears which I
collected in my tumblr and I tell you oh
wow whoa you know I've had a little bit
of a head cold the last couple days and
just that saline just that salt from
those tears totally clearing me up head
on over to Daily wire calm we'll be
right back with a lot more
I sound better already
Wow oh my goodness gracious I feel so
great from those leftist tears there's a
big story out now from Google and
YouTube about the Trump campaign Google
has removed more than 300 ads from
president Trump's re-election campaign
they did that over the summer so I don't
even what they're doing now Google and
YouTube removed that Google is YouTube's
right to the same company they've
removed the ads for quote violating
company policy ok fair enough what's the
policy they has been told anybody the
video ads were paid for by trumps 2020
presidential campaign Donald Trump J
Trump for president incorporated they
ran them for several days on YouTube
before they were taken down there was an
investigation into this by 60 minutes on
CBS this is the silver lining of the
whole story
mainstream media never do their job
mainstream media absolutely terrible
hacks right in bed with the left and yet
60 minutes actually looked into this
story Lesley Stahl who I think is
actually a great TV journalist she's
never been of the Jim Acosta variety
she's always been relatively more fair
Lesley Stahl and 60 minutes sat down
with Susan Lucci key I don't know if I'm
pronouncing that correctly frankly I
don't care
Susan is the YouTube CEO Lesley Stahl
sat her down and asked her directly
about the YouTube takedowns of Trump's
ads president Trump has been advertising
a lot on YouTube lately have you taken
down any of president Trump's ads at all
there are ads of President Trump that
were not approved to run on Google or
YouTube do you have an example well
they're available in our transparency
report there it is the transparency
report those ads are available on the
transparency report well maybe they are
maybe they aren't because the report
doesn't seem very transparent I want to
stress here that having your ads removed
on YouTube maybe it's not a big deal if
you're a company or you're another
political candidate because you're
advertising all over the place
what's crucial to know here is that
YouTube was incredibly important in
president Trump's 2016 strategy this is
not some secret conspiracy theory every
major political analyst admits this
Trump beat Hillary on social media
specifically on YouTube even on the
election day Trump was running big
banner ads for his campaign
the Clinton campaign wasn't really doing
that so YouTube in particular was
instrumental in the Trump victory the
left was furious about this that's why
the left has spent the last three years
crying and whining about how Republicans
did better than them on social media and
that's not supposed to happen which is
why they're now clamoring to had
Facebook and Twitter and YouTube to
censor conservatives shut up
conservatives direct people away from
conservatives and specifically President
Trump
point them in the left-wing direction
because that could sway who knows thirty
million votes or more so she says it's
in the transparency report to their
credit lesley stahl and CBS do not take
that for an answer that non answer for
an answer they ran the story they
followed the story and they pushed back
on the BS answer here she is kind of
Google keeps an archive of political ads
and we looked at president Trump's ads
over 300 videos were taken down mostly
over the summer but the archive doesn't
detail what rules they violated there's
no transparency in the transparency
report the ads typically did run for a
few days before they were taken down and
Google got paid for them good honor I
mean good on her for following a story
this by the way is all that
conservatives are asking for it's all
we're asking for if journalists the the
investigative journalists on TV would
just actually investigate if the
reporters would just actually report
even if they have their opinions even if
they have their preferences and their
biases that's fine
we're actually ok with that if you just
give any even slight modicum of fairness
if the media all behaved like Lesley
Stahl here you would not hear all of the
applause when President Trump calls out
the fake news media so she looks at at
300 ads removed
from YouTube from the Trump campaign and
the transparency report doesn't offer
any transparency so what is the YouTube
CEOs answer she says there is no bias
against conservatives as you know
conservatives think that you
discriminate against them how do you
answer that well first of all there are
lots of very successful conservatives
creators on YouTube our systems are they
don't have any concept of understanding
you know what's a Democrat what's a
Republican that's not true I say this as
a conservative who's on YouTube sure
your two Bloods conservatives exist
sometimes they don't totally throttle us
conservatives are disproportionally
attacked and demonetised and restricted
and targeted I have been the object of
this on many occasions Prager University
has been the object of this steven
crowder was demonetized by by YouTube
for videos that YouTube admitted did not
violate its policies any a YouTube D
monetized him anyway YouTube will target
regularly if you want to just talk about
the algorithm YouTube targets
conservative videos including my own to
try to debunk the claims that we're
making I'll give you an example a long
time ago I did a video about climate
change about global warming YouTube you
can go look it up YouTube actually added
a disclaimer below my video to say that
global warming is real it's seriously
happening it's going to destroy the
world they added this global warming
alarmism banner underneath my video to
try to debunk my video they don't do
that for liberals they don't do that so
what the CEO of YouTube just said is not
true now are they totally blocking
conservatives no they still let us do
our show that's nice glad to hear it but
what lesley stahl is asking for in this
report what we are asking for is not
special treatment it's not even fair
treatment it's just transparency and yet
we don't get any of that transparency
lesley stahl gives the CEO the last word
we do hear this criticism from all sites
we also have people who come from more
liberal rockhounds who complain about
discrimination
and so I think that no matter who you
are we are trying to enforce our
policies in a consistent way for
everybody that isn't true if they did
that maybe they're trying to do that if
they succeeded at doing that if they
just were consistent and even-handed
about it
nobody would complain about them it's
true that liberals whine about YouTube
but liberals will whine about everything
so that's not a big shock the fact of
the matter is conservatives are treated
more harshly on YouTube with less
transparency and less fairness then the
leftist that's just the way it is this
is all about 20/20 this was not true
before the 2016 election before the 2016
election conservatives did great on
YouTube because we have been shut out of
the mainstream media so now that we had
this opportunity to bypass those
gatekeepers we did great that helped us
win the 2016 election the left is really
doing their darndest not to let us
accomplish that again and it's not just
the politicians it's not just big tech
it's also the government bureaucracy
itself so if you haven't read it there's
really no need to I'll give you the
highlights right now The Daily Beast
left one publication just published a
13-page interview with lisa page you'll
remember lisa page is one of the
adulterous FBI agents who revealed in
text messages that there was a
conspiracy at the FBI to try to overturn
the 2016 election or to try to rig it
against president Trump this is not
tinfoil hat territory you can read the
text messages themselves Sochi has
rightly been pilloried by the right and
by even the center for her inappropriate
behavior she was also pilloried by the
FBI she was also pilloried by the
Inspector General and she says that
she's a big victim now it is true on
occasion you might say president Trump
has been particularly harsh on ELISA
page here's president from talking about
her at a recent rally on the FBI server
so their spouses wouldn't find out
because they didn't want to put it on
their private that didn't work out too
well for Peter struck at least okay
instead
least I love you I love you Lisa I love
you Lisa I love you so much I can't even
see straight lis Lisa she's gonna win
100 million to nothing but just in case
Lisa my darling I love you God
just in case she doesn't win we've got
an insurance policy essentially saying
we're gonna take him out
these are corrupt people folks
and then she said Peter I love you I
love you so much
you're so great Peter I don't think she
loves him too much anymore okay that's
really inappropriate and not funny at
all so don't you dare laugh at that
don't you dare laugh at President Trump
making fun of the two corrupt FBI
officials who were cheating on their
spouses you know betraying their
families and children to have this
affair together and and I don't even
really care about that too much what
people do in their private lives is
there a problem it's gonna be their
problem before God but you know I've got
more things to worry about
they were also betraying their public
office by promising one another via text
and to overturn the 2016 election to
undermine the 2016 election referring to
meetings that happened in FBI senior
officials offices that discussed
overturning that 2016 election what
President Trump was doing there was
enacting a it was re-enacting the text
messages that we can all read okay here
are the text messages from from Lisa
Paige Lisa Paige texted about Hillary
Clinton and and specifically taking
pressure off of Hillary Clinton during
that investigation into her email server
she said she might be our next president
the last thing we need is us going in
there loaded for bear when it's not
operationally necessary you think she's
gonna remember her care that it was more
the DOJ than the FBI this is as much
about reputational protection as
anything in other words take the
pressure off Hillary she'sshe's gonna be
our next president you know you don't
need to go of that heart against her
shortly after the 2016 election struck
texted Lisa Paige struck as her lover
oMG I'm so depressed Paige replied I
don't know if I can eat I'm very
nauseous she meant to say nauseated
people confuse those two words all the
time but a minor detail we move on page
asks quote he's never going to become
president right right this is this is
running for president he's never gonna
become president right right struck
replies no no he won't we'll stop it
will stop who's we the FBI he's talking
about him in the FBI as we know that the
FBI is engaging in surveillance of
President Trump's campaign trying to
undermine president Trump's campaign
that's really bad from my perspective as
an American citizen that's a lot worse
than cheating on your husband and kids
or cheating on your wife and kids
because you were betraying the public
trust that you had and now she's going
on offense to pretend that she's a
victim why is she doing him now she's
doing it now because you got the IG
report coming out she's doing it now
because you got the John Durham
investigation coming at all these
investigations into the 2016 election
into how the rush investigation began in
the first place
into the very corruption that Lisa Paige
and Peter struck or texting about so
she's going on offense
Lisa Paige is not a victim all right
president Trump did not cause her
trouble she caused her trouble according
to the FBI this is an FBI's internal
investigation page inflicted damage to
the FBI that went quote to the heart of
the FBI's reputation for neutral
fact-finding and political independence
that's not an awful right-wing website
that said that that's not president
Trump who said that that's the FBI
according to the Inspector General pages
text messages had quote potentially
indicated or created the appearance that
investigative decisions were impacted by
bias or other improper considerations
it's not Trump who said that that's not
mean old Michael or mean old daily wire
or mean old conservative TV that's the
Inspector General who said that okay and
yet he or she is Lisa page talking about
how she is a victim Lisa speaks there's
no fathomable way I have committed any
crime at all by the way no one's really
saying that she committed a crime we're
wondering if crimes were committed at
the FBI and DOJ but we're saying is she
acted inappropriately she did
straighted political bias she undermines
the neutrality of the FBI she abused her
power and she sent messages that were
indicating that the FBI abused its power
that's indisputable that's what happened
that's a very bad thing so ironic you
know you were now in this impeachment
investigation where the Democrats are
saying who cares if Trump committed a
crime he abused his power and that's
enough to impeach him now Lisa Paige is
saying I didn't commit a crime maybe she
did maybe she didn't I don't I don't
think she did she abused her power the
FBI in general abused its power that is
some pretty bad stuff and you're gonna
see a lot more of this coming down the
pike because we're about to get the
Inspector General report on how the
Russian investigation began in the first
place and there are already shenanigans
with that there have been some
conservatives who thought yes the
Inspector General report is gonna come
out and it's gonna take down this
corrupt cabal of bureaucrats that has
been operating with impunity and the
federal government and this I G report
is gonna take them down I never thought
that I never believed that do you think
the bureaucracy is gonna take down the
bureaucracy I don't think so the
bureaucracy has been remarkably durable
since it was created it's it's existed
for over a century now that wasn't going
to happen but the elected people the
people the appointed people the people
who have some accountability to We the
People or fighting back so there's a new
report out Attorney General William Bar
is reportedly refuting a key claim made
by the Justice Department Inspector
General Michael Horowitz in the
soon-to-be-released report Barr has
reportedly told associates that he
disagrees with the IG conclusion that
quote the FBI had enough information in
July 2016
to justify launching an investigation
into members of the Trump campaign now
that's according to the Washington Post
so take it with a grain of salt
The Post says though Barr has not been
swayed by horowitz's rationale for
concluding that the FBI had sufficient
basis to open an investigation on July
31st 2016
the
Attorney General has privately contended
that Horowitz does not have enough
information to reach the conclusion that
the FBI had enough details in in hand at
the time to justify opening such a probe
he argues that other agencies such as
the CIA may hold significant information
they could alter Horowitz's conclusion
on that point
that's according to people familiar with
the matter now I think what the left is
going to tell you if this report turns
out to be true is see conservatives
there was no there there there was
nothing real and now you're all just
complaining because the investigation
didn't turn up anything hold up just a
minute we could predict that the IG
wasn't going to expose the bureaucracy
here we could predict that number of
months ago and we did predict that a
number of months ago and I suspect
Attorney General Barr predicted that a
number of months ago which is why he
also appointed John Durham the federal
prosecutor to investigate this matter
separately when the when the Durham
investigation was announced when Durham
was appointed a lot of people didn't
take any notice the people who did take
notice said wait a second why is Durham
launching an investigation just now
become a criminal investigation if the
IG is just going to file their report
it's because we knew that the IG report
wasn't gonna have teeth might show you
something but it wasn't gonna have teeth
so the real story is gonna come out from
John Durham or at whoa I mean there's a
chance that there's no there there I'm
totally open-minded to that but it would
appear from everything that we've seen
from the text messages we've read from
the investigations that were launched
from the spying that did take place we
know for a fact it took place on the
Trump campaign and now from AG bars
reported conclusions it would seem that
all of us had the right hunch in the
first place and there will be a lot more
to this story takes a lot longer to take
down those psychos here on psycho
Tuesday it's not cycle Monday anymore
psycho Tuesday tune back in tomorrow on
Wednesday in the meantime I'm Michael
Moses as the Michael Dole show see you
them
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boy
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis clever
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens assistant director pavel white
house key
edited by Danny D'Amico audio is mixed
by Mike or Amina hair and makeup is by
Joshua alvera and our production
assistant is Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20:19 if you prefer
facts over feelings aren't offended by
the brutal truth and you can still laugh
at the insanity filling our national
news cycle well tune in to the Ben
Shapiro show we'll get a whole lot of
that and much more see you there